When you invest in a stock,...
...you're taking a risk that the value may go down rather than up.
Okay, we get it.
Investing can be risky.
One way to manage that risk is to learn about asset allocation and diversification.
Asset allocation is financial lingo for how you distribute your money...
...across types of investment like the strategic decision...
...of which baskets to put your eggs in and how many.
The different baskets are called asset classes.
To help you decide where to put your eggs,...
...ask yourself how much time do you have before you need to use your money,...
...how comfortable are you with risk, and how does your current financial situation look.
Diversification is about strategically putting the right mix of different eggs...
...in each of your baskets.
The key is that you shouldn't invest all your money in one company,...
...one industry, one country, one anything.
Ideally, you want your investments to be negatively correlated,...
...so when one is going down, another is going up.
Here are some typical ways to diversify your portfolio:...
...invest in companies in different countries,...
...own stock in small and large companies,...
...and invest in companies in a variety of industries.
One downside to diversification is...
...if one of your investments does very well,...
...you won't make as much as if it was your only investment.
Conversely, if you owned only one stock...
...and the company went out of business,...
...you will lose more money than if you had diversified your money.
Diversification won't eliminate risk...
...but it's a smart way to manage risk...
...while allowing you to build your portfolio.